Frequently, you'll want to show
content on top of imagery,
particularly icons or text.
When doing so, you'll need to ensure
that it is clear and legible.
This is especially important for
dynamic content when you
don't know exactly what the color or
how complicated the image will be.
For example, with this dark image,
we can see the title text and
the share icon but
if the image given to us is light,
the title and icon get somewhat lost.
For the overlayed icon,
we can use a subtle shadow on the image
to separate it from the background.
Here we've added a subtle dark
shadow to the white icon so
that it's visible, even if the content
behind is similarly colored.
Third, text,
adding shadows are possible but
it can make the text itself
somewhat harder to read.
A better approach is to
use what we call a scrim.
Now this is a semitransparent
layer between the image and
the text to help provide contrast and
legibility.
Here we're using a gradient
scrim which goes from 30% opaque
black at the bottom to
complete transparency.
The black gives enough contrast for
the overlayed white text to be readable.
Let's take a look at the scrim
from an angle giving you a clearer
representation of what is going on.
Now, the gradient sits on top of
the image but below the overlayed text.
We could have used a solid block of
color, rather than the gradient,
which would reduce the overall
impact on the image but
the sudden change can be distracting.
You should choose the size of your
scrim and the opacity values to get
the best legibility without
distracting from the image.
To implement this technique,
we can use a gradient drawable
placed on top of an image view.
Here, we're creating a gradient and
it's going to fade from this color here,
which is 30% opaque black,
at the bottom to completely
transparent at the center and top.
We can then use a FrameLayout
to stack our views.
First, we place the ImageView at
the back to display the picture.
Next, we place a View which has
that scrim drawable we just created
that's set as its background.
Finally, we place
a TextView on top of it,
which is going to draw
the text here at the bottom.
Don't be afraid of layering
content on top of imagery.
It can be a great effect for
creating a mess of apps.
Do, however, be careful to make
sure that it's always legible.